a movie's effects team made a fantastic
effort to ensure historical authenticity
and their Recreation of one of the
world's most harrowing moments so it's
no surprise that writer director
Christopher Nolan had to adapt the
Trinity test for his epic biopic
Thriller Oppenheimer I mean we always
knew the Trinity test would have to be a
showstopper it's the fulcrum that the
whole story turns on after featuring CGI
explosions in his 2012 film The Dark
Knight Rises a digital version of the
Trinity test just wouldn't cut it so he
asked Andrew Jackson his visual effects
supervisor from tenet for help as Nolan
explained I wanted to take CG off the
table and see if he could come up with
real world methodologies for producing
the effect of the first atomic blast
Nolan wasn't expecting his team to
design a version of the bomb in such
exacting detail but that was exactly
what they ended up doing which allowed
the production to move forward in an
exciting Direction